في ما يبدوبارا سياسيا واقتصاديا هو اصعب
بالنسبه لرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون
بعد اقل من ثمانيه اشهر على ولايته
الثانيه
يعود الفرنسيون الى الشارع مئات الالاف من
العمال والموظفين اختاروا سلاح الاضراب عن
العمل ورفع الصوت عاليا رفضا لمشروعي
حكومته الساعي لاصلاح نظام التقاعد والذي
ينصه في ابرز تعديلاته على رفع سن التقاعد
الى 64 عاما بدلا من 62
شلل اضراب قطاعات حيويه عديده وابرزه
النقل والصحه والطاقه والتعليم
وتسبب في تعطيل حركه المواصلات وخفض انتاج
الكهرباء واغلاق المدارس في عدد من مدن
البلاد كما امتنع عاملونها في وسائل
الاعلام الحكوميه وموظفون في وزاره
الخارجيه عن العمل
وفق استطلاعات الرئيس ان خطه ماكرون تواجه
رفضا للراي العام ومعارضه من احزاب اليسار
واليمين المتطرف وهو ما اظهره التجاوب
الكبير مع دعوات النقابات الرئيسيه
الثماني في البلاد التي تحركت ضمن جبهه
موحده للمره الاولى منذ 10 عاما
همم بالنظر الى مستوى الاستياء والسوست
اعتقد ان هذه الاحتجاجات لا يمكن الا ان
تجتد وتتوسع الكره في ملعب الحكومه انه
مشروعهم واذا سحبوه لن يكون هناك تعبئه
نحن جاهزون ولدينا حلول بشان كيفيه تحسين
النظام الحالي وليس تغييره او جعلنا نعمل
لفتره اطول
في المقابل تعتبر الحكومه ومن خلفها
الرئيس ماكرو ان مشروعهم الاصلاحي خطوه لا
مفر منها للضمان عدم افلاسين نظام التقاعد
فتمديده فتره العمل هو الخيار الامثل
لمواجهه التدهور الماليين للصناديق
التقاعد وشيخوخه السكان
التي تكلف فيها اعداد الاشخاص النشطين
اقتصاديا ويتزاد عدد المتقاعدين اكثر
فاكثر اذا كنت تريد ان يكون الميثاق بين
الاجيال منصفا فيجب تنفيذ هذا الاصلاح
لكن النقابات تجادل بان هناك وسائل اخرى
لضمان استمرار نظام التقاعد مثل فرض ضرائب
على فاحشه الثراء او زياده مساهمات اصحاب
العمل او مساهمات اصحاب الرواتب العاليه
في حين يكمل الاختبار الثاني لرئيس ماكرون
بان المشروع الحكومي سيمر الى الجمعيه
الوطنيه الفرنسيه التي لا يملك فيها
الاغلبيه المطلقه
[موسيقى]